i was start
when i was 14 years old with fernando
i make my first film with him
the name of the film is shanghai spell
and
five years later he calls me
and he says
hello aida how are you you're okay and i
said yes i'm okay fernando how are you
and he says
i want just
to know if you speak french or not
and i say no i don't speak french why
no i think of you for a character but
i'm not sure okay you are fine okay bye
wow
and
at this moment i was very nervous
because i thinking a lot and
i packed and i
i live all my boyfriend my house all and
i
i went to france
and i learned french
and six months later i called fernando
in french
fernando
i didn't recognize her really it takes
me some
half a minute or something one minute
because
uh i i do either really and you speak
french
since when
and and then she she tells me that
that's she's calling me from france
and uh that she's living in montpellier
and he says you're living in montpellier
yeah and uh and you and friends say yeah
yeah yeah
when you came to france and she says two
weeks after you called me
and i say oh my god
i haven't even
written the script yet
i was just thinking about it i i was
thinking cheers because i'm
lazy and slow
and
but okay finally some
some years after
four years after i gave her the script
and when i have discrete i was afraid
because i changing all of my life for
this and
she didn't know what it was about and
and i watched naked naked naked
but
this is a story very beautiful and very
special and
and working with him is very special for
me because
he give me the first opportunity
and this movie is very special for me
too for the character and i was always
in the screen
there was
something very sensitive and really
beautiful
and i'm so happy
one of the wonders of this film is the
extraordinary performance of jean
rochefort and i wonder is it true that
he was about to retire before you came
to him with the
project
no what what happened is that when uh i
gave him the script and then
he called me he told me he loved the
script and loved the character and and
uh so
i i went to paris to to met with him and
to talk
and in this very first meeting
he told me
let's do that movie i loved it
i wanted to be my last movie
i was looking for
the right character the right
movie to end my career and i say oh my
god
what a responsibility
why
but i start to think
in that movie when two
two things get together in my mind one
was uh uh
two things that had fi i i've been a fan
of art and i want i dreamed to be a
painter when i was a boy i painted until
18
that i stopped
thanks for
art history
and
i was always fascinated by aristide my
old
obsession on female body and making
of that practically the only subject in
his whole work in his whole life i was
always also fascinated by the obsession
because of having his last years with
the
the painter and the model
the artist and the model
the atelier of the artist
the gas at his atelier all this
continual variation on the same thing
one after another in different drawings
and canvases and
you you can see that it was not just the
artist and the model but the
it was about uh old age and job
about
life and death and beauty and and it was
uh i always think it was
his way of fighting death of of trying
to to to grab life and to to be still
alive and and to keep his energy and all
the last period of picasso is quite wild
quite
very strong very
sometimes cruel even uh very sexual no
maybe it was because my uh
brother maximo who was
14 months older than i
uh he was he really was a born artist
and when he was like this he he was he
was an uh
he was an incredible uh painter and red
man and then he became
a sculptor and and and as a boy you are
always watching your older brother and
trying to imitate him and to copy him
and uh
so
maybe
my life has been this because of him you
know
and art is something material
art is not
concept it's not ideas
even if for making a movie you you deal
sometimes with ideas but movies are
about feelings about
real people about life about love about
dead about things the ideas are there
obviously but we are not philosophers we
we tell stories no